l'air ne serait-elle finalement pas plus
verte au pays pour des milliers de
vénézuéliens ayant fui en raison de la
crise politique puis économique ce
constat semble se dessiner service
public et loyers gratuits sont les deux
principales raisons qui poussent
aujourd'hui ces exilés en colombie à
rentrer mais voilà avec la pandémie due
qu'aux vide 19 et depuis la fermeture
des frontières entre les deux pays
le retour au venezuela est compliqué
pour beaucoup d'entre eux en quarantaine
dans un pays qui n'est pas le leur
pourtant les autorités colombiennes
assure avoir tout mis en oeuvre pour
faciliter le flux des migrants
même si les passages quotidiens sont
limitées nous avons un nombre déterminé
de passage autorisés vers le venezuela
et nous travaillons sur la base de celui
ci il nous a été possible de faciliter
la traversée par coup compta il ya des
gros are you how cas hélas guaje cra
mais les passages quotidiens sont
limitées par la situation restait
inchangée au venezuela qui fait que le
manque d'organisation peut affecter le
fonctionnement de ces points frontaliers
si bogota pointe une certaine
désorganisation de la part de caracas le
président vénézuélien nicolas maduro se
veut rassurant et encourage ses
ressortissants à rentrer nous pouvons
accueillir les milliers de vénézuéliens
qui viennent du brésil du chili du pérou
d'équateur et de colombie et qui ont fui
ces pays qu'ils ont fui la mort le
corona virus la persécution et la
xénophobie
venez au venezuela fait toute la
quarantaine soyez reçu dans ma région
fait un bilan de santé vérifier que vous
n'avez pas le coronavirus et rentrez
chez vous en bonne santé
embrassez votre famille et reprendre
votre vie et contribuer à la
construction du venezuela pour les
vénézuéliens toujours bloqués à la
frontière la situation est pénible et
les conditions sanitaires déplorables
ça fait mal parce que nous ne pensions
pas que ça se passerait comme ça
nous pensions que nous tiendrions ici et
que nous serions bien accueilli que nous
allions pouvoir rentrer dans notre
il que la procédure serait plus rapide
un virus circule nous ne pouvons pas
être entassés trop longtemps car nous ne
savons pas qui est contaminée nous avons
dû dormir et nous réveiller ici sur le
pont simon bolivar nous ne voulons pas
rester une nuit de plus nous voulons que
le gouvernement fasse son travail et
nous aide nous souhaitons que chacun
rejoindre sa maison sa région weiler
famille des retours long et difficile
donc mais aussi un risque sanitaire
accrue pour des dizaines de vénézuéliens
qui attendent toujours de pouvoir
retrouver leurs familles